I'm standing here on the roof
of the Royal Institution.
And I'm using something that
we take for granted in the
modern technological world, a
compass, using GPS built into
my smartphone.
And I can use it to find the
direction to magnetic north,
which is that way, which means
that south is that way.
Which means Spain is over 1,000
kilometres in that direction.
I'm interested because what we
think we're very clever at
doing, nature has figured
out before us.
Lots of migrating birds and
marine animals have built-in
compasses in their brains, in
their eyes, at the ends of the
beaks, so they can detect the
direction they should travel.
One bird in particular, however,
does something much
more clever.
The European Robin uses quantum
mechanics to find its
way to Spain.
That's why I'm so interested.
What's becoming increasingly
clear is that the humble
European Robin finds its way
south from Scandinavia to the
Mediterranean every winter by
following and seeing Earth's
magnetic field.
And it does this with special
molecules, proteins inside its
retina called cryptochrome.
Essentially, these are
light-activated, and they
produce something called
quantum entanglement.
Light enters the bird's retina
and knocks one of a pair of
electrons off an atom and
onto a neighbouring one.
These two electrons, though,
remain somehow coordinated in
their actions.
We say they're quantum
entangled.
And because they're far apart,
their actions are sensitive to
the direction of the Earth's
magnetic field.
What happens next is that the
direction of the field affects
the way they cause chemical
reactions to take place,
sending signals to the bird's
brain, telling it which
direction to go.
Now, this is not only
surprising but very
fascinating for physicists,
because we're used to trying
to control the delicate quantum
world inside our
sterile controlled laboratory
experiments.
So the notion that nature has
got there first, that somehow
these delicate quantum phenomena
can be maintained
inside the warm, messy, complex
environment of a
living cell, is nothing short
of miraculous, and until
recently has been very
controversial.
But it's the reason why so many
biologists and quantum
physicists are becoming very,
very excited, because it may
be that the weird world of
quantum mechanics plays a
vital role in biology.
Quantum entanglement is the idea
that particles, however
far apart they are, still
somehow, their fates remain
intertwined.
They are still aware of each
other's existence.